welcome to the Los Angeles Times Book
Festival my name is Robert Lee hoax I'm
one of the science writers for The Times
and at my left is a UCLA professor Jared
Diamond and I want to welcome all of you
to a conversation with Professor diamond
I some housekeeping matters first I want
you all to know that there will be book
signings with Professor diamond taking
place after this conversation and north
areas see also later at crown and
tomorrow at noon at the UCLA book zone
booth so should that be something you're
interested in you'll have ample
opportunity to get your book signed have
a chance to talk to Jared it is one of
the particular privileges and pleasures
of what I do for a living as a science
writer that I am able to spend time with
some of the finest minds at work in the
world today who are shaping our views of
life to come but also are helping to
reshape our understanding of what has
passed before us certainly the progress
of science is always depended on the
ability of its popularizers to
forcefully articulate its findings just
as Darwin had his Huxley to argue the
case for evolution so physics today has
Stephen Hawking linguistics as Steven
Pinker psychology has Oliver Sacks
neuroscience as Antonio Damasio Daniel
Dennett Roger Penrose and anthropology
and evolutionary biology has Jared
Diamond as if it is the case as CPS know
so famously observed and our national
test scores appear to confirm every year
that there is a yawning gap between the
culture of the liberal arts and science
it is not for a want of trying
and today we
have with us and we have an opportunity
to talk with a distinguished scientist
who perhaps has done as much as anyone
today to close that gap dr. diamond is a
recent recipient of the National Medal
of Science the highest honor that this
nation can bestow upon a scientist it is
also worth noting that as the author of
a number of books but in particular Guns
Germs and Steel the fates of human
societies professor diamond received the
Pulitzer Prize for nonfiction he's a
member of the National Academy of
Sciences he's considered one of the
founders of conservation biology and
perhaps most importantly for our
discussion today he is a scientist who
in addition to rigorous field work and
lab work is also someone who writes
frequently for the general public on
scientific issues he writes for discover
he has often written for nature and what
I'm hoping to do today is to explore
some of the issues that dr. diamond has
written about and at the end of Maya
questions I'm going to invite you here
in the audience to join in the
conversation and to make that work I
will remind you now that we will have to
ask you to use the microphone in the
center aisle but I'll give you some
notice before we get to that point so
you can think of your question and get
to the mic as a writer it's very
striking how professor diamond
structures his books and Guns Germs and
Steel is particularly remarkable in that
way as a as an author he frames a very
sophisticated and very technical and
well explicate 'add discuss
you know the fates of human societies
around a simple question asked him by a
friend of his in New Guinea where
professor diamond has I think conducted
18 as of this year 18 field expeditions
and that question to paraphrase it is
why us why us and we're going to talk
about some of his answers to that
question but but first I thought we
might explore for a moment why you
and in that vein I'd like to ask you why
New Guinea could you tell us a little
bit about what led you to spend so much
of your career focused on New Guinea and
perhaps give us some sense of how an
interest in ornithology led to an
interest in the fate of human societies
why New Guinea and unbiased answer would
be that New Guinea is the most intensely
interesting beautiful stimulating place
in the world that's obviously a biased
answer but realistically there are some
things going for New Guinea I started to
work in New Guinea in 1964 when I was a
bachelor Iike for adventure and at that
time New Guinea counted as the wildest
most unexplored place in the world where
they were still lots of uncontacted
tribes when there were large areas that
were white on the map because they
weren't even aerial surveys of them and
New Guinea also has the most beautiful
wonderful birds in the world
the birds paradise bowerbirds many
parrots so I went out to New Guinea
initially studying birds but as soon as
I arrived in New Guinea literally on my
first day I was confronted with New
Guineans
the inhabitants of New Guinea who are
fascinating people until recently they
had all been using stone tools and they
had not had indigenous riding and they
were living in tribal societies they
were what is often called primitive
people and on my first day there going
out there naively thinking primitive
people primitive mines
I confronted the fact there's nothing
primitive without these people in their
minds these are really smart people
curious questioning why is it then that
I the dopes who can't light a fire in
the jungle why is that that I the dope
came in there with the steel axes and
riding and they these really smart
people why did they have the stone tools
so that question hit me immediately and
that was the question that eventually
grew into Guns Germs and Steel which is
really not the biggest
question of history why just we unfolded
differently for peoples of different
continents but I'm still want to force
you to stay centered on yourself for a
moment and
you arrived in New Guinea as a young
academic a young scientist with a
collection of questions that you have
about birds I'm just wondering if you
can tell us a little bit about how you
translated into your experience over
time into a shift in your own focus I
mean I understand what you've just said
but how did I change my focus partly it
was a matter of going back to my
original Fossey as a child I had done my
formal training in biochemistry and
gotten a PhD in physiology
UCLA I'm a professor here in UCLA hires
me to do laboratory research in the
science of physiology and to teach
physiology to graduate students medical
students and undergraduates but as a
child first of all I was born in 1937 so
history and geography staff my childhood
some of my earliest memories of being a
child was memories of my father
moving the pins on the maps on the wall
of our house to mark the shifting
battlefronts in World War 2 my mother
was an excellent linguist I got
interested in languages early on I had a
high school teacher who turned me on to
history when I went to college although
I took the required pre-med courses I
was also taking history courses and
language courses and then I did my
graduate work in in Europe living for
four years in Europe from 1958 to 1962
my friends my European friends were also
born in 1937 but if you were born in
1937 made a big difference whether you
were born in Japan Poland Germany Russia
England or the United States where you
were born firstly explain what your
subsequent life history was going to be
so I got turned on early to the question
have geography and history interact and
that's a long-winded way of saying how
did this all tend to meet when I went
when I started going to New Guinea it
brought me back to these early interests
in wide
rafi does different things to different
people's I ask the question because as
I'm sure you know scientists are famous
for minding their own business in a
technical sense and are beaten off with
sticks that they stray into other
people's areas and one thing that
distinguishes your work is its
willingness to synthesize thank-you is
willingness to synthesize lots of
strands from many different technical
fields now you bring up your interest in
geography you have been at a time when
University geography departments across
the country have been closed shut down
marginalized been called a geographic
determinist I wonder why you feel so
strongly in a broader way as a matter of
evolutionary biology as a matter of the
history of early societies that
geography is the determinant that's
putting it a little too strong to say
that geography is is the determinant
it's true as you say that geography has
been marginalized in schools over the
last 50 years when I started in college
I was an undergraduate at Harvard
started here in 1954 and Harvard then I
believe had just abolished its Geography
Department and there was a wave of
abolishing geography departments around
the United States in the mistaken belief
that geography consists of memorizing
state capitals and boundaries of states
well geography is much more than that
here at UCLA our Geography Department is
one of the largest and best in the
countries am i a geographic determinists
do I believe that geography is
everything in history no absolutely not
I met my wife through chance and thank
God for that chance
yes she was living in Los Angeles that's
geography but there are several million
other women who living in Los Angeles
and I'm glad that that given those
Geographic frames that I met Marie
rather than three million other women
but does this mean the geography that
everything in history is culture
idiosyncrasy that's ridiculous
obviously where you're born and when
you're born has a huge effect on life
experiences well you've been
gracious about tolerating my interest in
your own life experiences let me broaden
the conversation out just a tad here and
and move it from y-you back to why us
well why us
we can weaken frame this question in a
personal way just as I look out on this
room today here we are in North America
in California and if we had been at the
side of this room 500 years ago every
single person at this side in the year
1500 would have been of Native American
origin and as I look out at you today it
looks as if the vast majority of you
were of old world origin most of
European origin many of Asian origin
some of African origin I don't notice
any Aboriginal Australians or New
Guineans here and there are some of you
I believe of Native American origin we
are as if we were now if we were
conducting this discussion now stay in
London in Europe the vast majority
people there would be of Eurasian origin
some African origin again no Aboriginal
Australians New Guineans
and few people of Native American origin
to put it personally
why did history turn out that way why
didn't it turn out the reverse way why
was it not the case that the Aztec
emperor Montezuma had a fleet of ships
and sail to Europe and and conquered
Spain and then gradually exterminated
Europeans and drove last Europeans into
reservations up in the mountains and
infected the rest so they died of
diseases it didn't happen that way it
something close to that happened the
reverse way why how do we explain this
biggest question of history that's the
question well that is the question and
you framed it very nicely and I know you
spent a good chunk of your life trying
to answer it
and in so doing it's kind of required to
choose stray out of what I think even a
layperson would consider the study of
birds and into
although we're an unusual species and I
know you've addressed aspects of that in
another book of yours why is sex fun and
which I recommend it's a it's a charming
charming set of essays but it's it's
it's required you to stray out of your
original interest and into fields like
history economics which are not normally
the economists might argue with me but
not normally considered hard sciences
things are less quantifiable more
intuitive more literary if you like I'm
wondering how you met the standards that
you have as a scientist in wrestling
with something as fuzzy and uncertain
and in the end perhaps unknowable as our
past that's an interesting question I
would I would end my response with your
last comment about the past being
unknowable I would assert that the past
is knowable but to know it you have to
use different techniques from the
techniques of the hard sciences fine
after all hired to be a hard scientist
to practice physiology I work in the
laboratory and we do manipulative
experiments we set up experiments we've
run controls we've run the experiments
and controls five different times
setting the variables that's how one
operates in molecular biology and in
chemistry obviously it's not how one
operates in human history but when you
ask how did I then deal with these
issues of human history it's because
there are many areas that everybody
considers Sciences we everyone cannot
carry out manipulative laboratory
experiments for example astronomers to
understand the evolution of stars don't
go up there and turn off Dettol shifts
for three nights and make Aldebaran
twice as bright and see the result you
cannot not do manipulative experiments
in astronomy nor can you do manipulative
experiments in geology starting an ice
age here and melting glaciers over there
and epidemiology you all
can't do manipulative experiments we
can't understand the genetic basis for
resistance to smallpox by infecting 1
million people with smallpox and leaving
another million people as controls this
is a long-winded way of saying that
there are many sciences that are
historical sciences like astronomy and
geology in epidemiology and evolutionary
biology and ecology all these sciences
have developed methods for knowing for
getting at the answers and essentially
the same sorts of methods the
comparative methods and the methods of
the natural experiments work in human
history one of the margaret assert you
would assert you draw together several
threads in in your synthesis of the
human past and attempting to address the
evolution of modern societies and one of
them is your view of the biological
fallacies of race and I want to quote
you here with that with a line from an
article that you wrote for discover in
the early 1990s the reality of human
races is another common-sense quote
truth unquote destined to follow the
Flat Earth into oblivion I wonder if you
could share with us just what you mean
by that statement and your own views of
race sure my own views of race if you
start off with what one could call and
I'm not being pejorative about this a
naive or a simple-minded view if you
look at people most of us can look at
people and we'll know immediately what
continent that person came from we can
instantly with a 100% certainty
distinguish a native Swede from a native
Nigerian from a native Japanese and that
then suggests classifying people
pigeonholing people into categories it
suggests that we can do it with complete
success we can distinguish Nigerians
from Japanese from Swedes and never make
mistake does that mean then that you can
define
racists say a European race and Asian
race that African race it doesn't work
for two reasons one reason is
integration it's not enough to compare
Swedes with Nigerians you have to
compare Swedes with Germans with
Italians with North Africans with
Ethiopians with Congolese with Nigerians
you get gradation as you move around the
world and the other thing is that
usually we classify people based on
external appearance of course
particularly on the things we can see
best in color I call a hair color and
hair form doesn't mean that
classification based on external
characteristics maps against a
classification based on internal
characteristics not at all if you
classify people say based on their
resistance malaria you would come up
with a completely different
classification you would classify
Italians together with Nigerians and you
would classify Swedes together with
Zulus or hoses so that racial so-called
racial classifications are based on caps
one half of one percent of human genetic
variation doesn't predict other sorts of
human genetic variation and so-called
races grade into each other finally the
concept of race of course is just a
blueprint for social prejudice and
trouble therefore let's forget about
race
one thing that you somewhat startling I
think to some of us that the the to site
is and have a major agent and helping
European civilization achieve the sort
of supremacy of Western civilization
whatever we want to call it that it
enjoys today is in fact disease and I
wonder why it is that Eurasia seemed to
develop such deadly diseases and why the
populations of North and South America
the native populations did not what why
why were the the you were talking
earlier about that boats going the other
way why didn't the germs go the other
way and fast you could yeah explain your
thinking there that's a great question
that's one of the crucial questions in
history
why diseases moved in such a symmetrical
fashion around the world the European
conquest of the new world the title of
my book dreamed up a cross by my wife
Guns Germs and Steel on germs something
like 95 percent of Native Americans died
in bed of European diseases leaving 5
percent to fight it out in the
battlefield with wooden wooden and on
stone weapons versus steel swords so to
understand why germs came from Eurasia
to the new world rather than from new
world to Eurasia that's one of the key
questions in history that's one of the
major reasons behind the European
conquest that also illustrates why the
question behind Guns Germs a sealed the
uneven pattern of history while the
question could not have been answered
until the last 20 years and why could
not have been answered by historians but
requires study by scientists and
biologists it turns out that the major
killers of humanity the crowd infectious
diseases by smallpox measles TB mumps
etc plague the diseases that killed off
most Native Americans these the diseases
that evolved only within the last 10,000
years
from crowd diseases of our domestic
animals but out of the world's 14 big
domestic mammals 13 were Eurasian cow
sheep goat for spitting camera etc etc
there's only one big mammal that was
domesticated in the new world the llama
Europeans Eurasian simply grew up next
these domestic mammals breathed in the
germs grank
the milk rubbed their skin with a saliva
the domestic animals got infected with
say wind a pest of cattle which then
mutated into measles of humans so
Eurasians because most large mammals
were domesticated in Eurasia not on the
Americas ended up with the nasty
diseases you can then push the question
back further and ask why is that that
most most animals were domesticated in
Eurasia rather than the new world but
that's progressively pushing back the
sequence of questions behind big pattern
history well but that's sort of half
half the the answer perhaps or an answer
to half the question you've now explain
to me why my European ancestors were a
disease ridden germy bunch who should
have been washing their hands much more
than they did but what I'm still puzzled
at is why a similar Arsenal if I can put
it that way of bacterial infections and
pages and such didn't arise and what we
like to call a new world right well why
didn't a similar similar arsenal of
nasty microbes evolved in the new world
the answer is the Thea was practically
no starting material the starting
material for the nasty diseases of
humans were nasty diseases of our
domestic animals with which we began
coming in contact with the first
domestication of sheep and goats and
pigs in Fertile Crescent 8500 BC but the
only big mammal domesticated in the new
world was the llama
they were also domesticated a few other
things llamas turkeys guinea pigs must
be ducks but that's not much compared to
the dozens and dozens of domesticated
animals in Europe so they were very few
animal germs in the New World to jump
over into Native Americans there were
lots of animal germs in the old world to
jump over into
native Eurasians and when they jump
native durations gradually evolved both
antibodies and genetic resistance to
these diseases which Native Americans
did not but there were no such nasty
diseases in the new world to which
Native Americans could have evolved
resistance to wiped out Europeans
looking at the steel variable and your
equation of Guns Germs and Steel it
certainly is the case in in terms of
fundamental technologies that many of
the devices or some of the key devices
that European civilizations seized on is
a tool of conquest whatever we're
actually developed say in China and yet
we're not used gunpowder's a good
example I suppose is this the most
obvious one that was never really
thought of as a kind of tool of
aggression in quite the same way was
good for fireworks good for occasionally
you know blowing up a wall perhaps but
but not systematically I'm exploited and
I sort of wonder we've been talking
about why your Asia and not the new
world but why more that can be
Eurocentric for a moment why more Europe
and not China where it's in some
respects needs have been a much more
creative cradle for a variety of
technological innovations that seem to
have played such key roles later on
that's right Chuck it was within Eurasia
um China was where were invented
gunpowder printing deep drilling
bulkheads and ships porcelain etc etc in
fact if an extraterrestrial from the
planet Mars had come to the world come
to earth in the year 1300 and was asked
to predict who is going to take over the
world the extra-terrestrial would have
sent us a no grain or China because
trying to lead the world and Technology
by had by far the bigger ships and the
best ships and was starting to send
those ships to the coast
Africa so it looked as if Chinese fleets
were bout to round the coast of African
come up and smooshy Europeans but it
didn't work out that way why not well my
book is mostly about comparisons between
continents
I knew though that I could not get away
with a book on the big pattern history
without asking at the end why within
continents Europe not China and so in
the last chapter of Guns Germs and Steel
by of nine pages in which to my
satisfaction but not that of most
historians I saw and the answer is in my
opinion it has nothing to do with
Confucianism as is often cited it has
nothing to do with the judeo-christian
tradition ask Galileo about the virtues
of the judeo-christian tradition for
advancing technology and science it has
everything to do with geography if you
look at a map of China and look at a map
of Europe Europe is highly indented with
those peninsulas and mountains and
rivers flowing radially the coastline of
China is smooth the rivers run parallel
and were quickly joined by canals no
transecting mountains and the result is
that China was unified 221 BC and has
been unified most of the time since then
Europe has never been unified the EEC
the European Economic Community can't
bring it off today and the result is
that Europe has always been a mixture of
competing States it meant that whenever
an inventor was getting hassled in one
country the invent two went to another
country Columbus remember goth rejected
in Italy and France and Portugal it took
him seven tries before he got someone
who would give him ships in China you
had only one chance the Emperor and if
the Emperor gave you ships falling
that's what happened in 1400 but in 1432
the emperor of China said enough that's
a waste that's waste money
no more ships and that ended ship going
technology throughout China so my answer
would be that China held the lead for a
long time but then China's geography did
it in for the same reason the China's
geography is doing it in today namely
the great Cultural Revolution of 25 on
years ago the decisions of a few idiots
at the head of the
world's largest country could destroy
the educational system for a billion
people that's impossible anywhere else
in the world
well now listening to you talk about how
important the role of microbes and germs
has been in to bringing us to where we
are today is a little hard on my ego and
I can't help but think that sort of
summing up and answering the course of
recent contemporary civilization and
nine pages is a little hard on the ego
of many historians I wonder if for all
the the self-evident popularity of your
work it's been on the bestseller list in
one way or another almost as long as
I've been a journalist do you find that
you have ruffled some feathers that
you've encountered some hostility when
you put your foot squarely on such
sacred cows there are two sets of
feathers that are that I've ruffled for
the most part do you get a lot of
Correspondence about my book and most of
it is favourable people really excited
and turned on by it um there are two
sorts of people who don't like the book
one are people whom are obviously
racists don't read the book and crypto
race us find their feathers ruffled you
would be astonished on how often this
happens to me I mean in the United
States we are taught it's not
politically correct to say that
Europeans have higher IQ than those
other people but time and timing within
the last few months I've talked to
cabinet ministers and inventors and
captains of industry and university
professors who say to me things like
well you know I don't like to say this
this isn't correct but but but let's
face it
Europeans are smarter than those other
people and they were more inventive in
the Judeo you ensure crypto racist
explanations so that's one one batch of
feathers ruffled the other batch of
feathers ruffled are from historians
themselves because most historians study
the history of relatively small areas
over short times
of UCLA has job ads for 18th century
French historians early 19th century
German historians but not world
historians over the past 13 thousand
years and yet in other historical
disciplines in ecology and epidemiology
and so on it's recognized that you have
to have the detail studies and you also
have to have the comparative studies
without the broad framework you can't
place the detailed studies in
perspective and understand their
significance
without the detailed studies you don't
have the factual base for forming the
broad framework so historians generally
um have been less interested in my book
than linguist archaeologist
anthropologist geneticist biochemist etc
etc and they certainly are some
historians whose feathers have been
ruffled I wonder as a follow-up to that
and then I should say in a few minutes
I'll ask you in the audience to join us
in our conversation here if you have
questions that you'd like to ask
professor diamond I ask you to start
thinking about them now and if you have
one to start winning your way to the
microphone in the center aisle there
it's crucial that you use the microphone
because otherwise no one will be able to
hear what you're talking about
now but as a follow-up to that certainly
it's long been a conventional thought
that to be a scientist and to talk to
the general public is a kind of risky
business there is the famous example of
Carl Sagan who in his generation perhaps
the most well-known scientist and
perhaps the one who did most to bring
various issues of astronomy and
planetary science before the general
public and a variety of mediums novels
film personal appearances book panel
discussions and it's thought that he
took a hit for this and there's a famous
incident involving the National Academy
of Sciences at which you are a member of
the National Academy is the
kind of the honorary society if you like
in this country for its most prominent
scientists and serves as an advisory
body to the US government the second was
proposed for membership and then
essentially blackballed so the story
goes one I kind of wonder if you think
with some distance now on on Sagan's
career whether that in fact he was ill
treated and whether you yourself who
among many things are quite active and
and quite successful popularizer of
science whether you have taken a hit
from your peers in the scientific
community yeah they're all problems
about professional scientists try to
communicate to the public there are
serious career problems the problems
arise because in science we learn to
write precisely defining our terms
without writing vividly without writing
poetically or beautifully the sense is
that if someone if you try to write
nicely or beautifully the implication is
that you're trying to cover up your bad
reasoning or your deficient facts with
your unpoetic style so it just goes
against the grain of scientists to write
in an interesting way that's necessary
to communicate ideas to a wider audience
into the public and this who calls Sagan
as smoke is the clearest example of
someone who took a hit he was
essentially elected in the first stage
and then turned down at the second stage
of elections for the National Academy of
Sciences I personally have not taken
much in the way of hits and I think
that's because I began writing for the
public relatively late in my career it
was until 1991 when I was 54 years old
that right I wrote my first book for the
public and wasn't until 1983 when I was
46 years old and it had ten year at UCLA
for something like 20 years by then that
I began writing even magazine articles
so I was well established and
another thing is that in addition to
writing for the public as I do now I've
carried on my technical career and
laboratory physiology at UCLA and so on
my my colleagues can judge me on my
technical stuff they can ignore all the
rest if they want but the physiology is
still gone okay whereas Carl Sagan
put more and more of his effort into
communicating to the public and into
public policy issues so it was then a
easy or cheap way out for his colleagues
to say well you know he's gone through
his scientific menopause he's doing this
stuff because he's all washed officer on
the career scientists but it is a big
problem for scientists who would like to
write for the public and my advice to
those of you who are scientists who
would like to communicate to the public
is get tenure first get well established
and then communicate to the public I see
we have some questioners lined up there
sir or if you have a question we'd love
to hear it yeah thank you can you hear
me okay
I did enjoy your book quite a bit I
noticed what for my mind as you approach
things from a cross-disciplinary
perspective which i think is valuable
I've noticed the lack of what you might
call the psycho spiritual dimension in
the human and one thing stuck in my mind
in the example given of the wheel in
Eurasia and the wheel in America is that
in Eurasia it had either a commercial or
military use and Eurasia was only seen
as something foreplay
somehow that does speak to an important
dimension and if in political structures
ie them the state the the commercial
will always overtake the play in the
human condition or species what does
that say for the future of our species
sure double question about the role of
cyclists of the psycho-spiritual
perspective in my book as specifically
as it affects the wheels there's very
little of the psycho-spiritual
perspective in my book not because it's
lacking in my life the most important
thing in my life are my children and my
wife and my friends but the book is
about a specific question namely why
history unfolded differently on
different continents and I've not been
it had been able to detect
psycho-spiritual differences between
different continents that explain why
certain peoples ended up conquering
other peoples instead the answers it
appears to me have to do with the wild
plants and animal species available for
domestication and the areas and
isolations and axes of the continents as
for the wheel in particular we we know
that the wheel was invented in the new
world and it's only at a station in the
new world is in some toys some toy
lottery in Mexico what was the origins
of wheel in Eurasia quite possibly also
for toys but in Eurasia the drast
animals were available and if the wheel
was invented for toys the wheel was then
quickly applied to graff transport so
that by 4000 BC the wheel was being used
and was in fact quickly spread over a
Eurasia for animal transport but in the
new world the only animal available big
enough to do any transport was the llama
it happened that the field was invented
in Mexico sometime around a thousand AD
there was no direct interchange between
Mexico and llamas and and the Andes
where the llama was domesticated
souldn't in the new world the wheel
never had a chance to meet Kalama if if
new world history had gone on without
spanish intervention for another five
thousand years I predict that wheels
would have met llamas and they would
have been wheeled transport in the new
world it was just a matter of time
yes sir mr. diamond I'm also a big fan
of your book enjoyed it thoroughly but I
guess it was the last few pages it may
be left
with some questions hanging and one in
particular like to ask you sort of how
Europe developed in advance of say China
it's a plausible explanation you have
but if one looks say within Europe how
does one explain that you had
flourishing of Greece and then Rome Rome
basically conquering the whole
Mediterranean area then European
civilization goes into eclipse for a
thousand years then it suddenly springs
up again with the Renaissance how does
one internally to Europe explain all
those developments does that one have to
add to geography a whole host of
economic and social situation
circumstances that that interact with
technological progress to produce the
types of changes that your book
addresses yes one does have to add more
economic social political factors but in
addition you would not be surprised to
hear me say that what has to add even
further Geographic and ecological
factors and in fact you hit on the
subject of my next book what what one of
the questions in my next book is
precisely that question why did
so-called Western civilization march
west was the North West words arising in
the Fertile Crescent shifting to Greece
what happened to the Fertile Crescent
shifting to Rome what happened to Greece
shifting to northwestern Europe you
won't be surprised that I discerned
Geographic and ecological factors behind
that but in five years bye-bye my next
book helped me write my next book and
we'll have the answers
sir.you next please
wanted to ask a question you mentioned
the sort of language and literary theory
of science is being different from
history do you think there's an
advantage to scientists and to
historians to maybe adopt some of the
language of the other either sign or at
other fields of inquiry the question is
there some advantage to scientists and
historians adopting the language of each
other many scientists already adopt the
language of history there are many
so-called historical sciences as an
evolutionary biologist I'm a historian
studying the history of birds and of
bird communities historians I think many
historians could profit by adopting some
of the approaches of science the
comparative approach but the raw
historians who already do this there's a
subfield of history called world history
there are courses in world history
there's a there's a society of world
history and Journal of world history so
this is a growing movement within world
history today that emphasizes the
comparative approach the broader
perspective yes please you've spoken
about the need for conservation do you
think that there's anything that we can
or should do about some of these peoples
and their cultures the indigenous
peoples that you spoke that you've
studied is there anything that we can
and should do about some of these
peoples and their cultures and
indigenous peoples well there are some
negative things that we can avoid doing
until very recently we meaning majority
Americans were were consciously
destructive of the cultures of Native
Americans for example until something
like twenty years ago it was essentially
illegal for an Indian child to speak an
Indian language in American schools and
if an Indian child spoken of Indian
language in American schools and it was
boarding school the kid had his or her
mouth washed up washed out with soap and
had no food for the day and had to scrub
stairs
so majority American culture was
explicitly destructive of Native
American culture and languages and
considered them worthless
some best eliminated now thank God um
there's not only toleration for a Native
American languages and cultures but some
positive support at a very low level the
federal government is putting a few
million dollars a year into studies
aimed at preserving Native American
languages that's long winded way of
saying that again many indigenous people
will do quite well at preserving
themselves and if only majority cultures
would lay off and not do conscious
things to destroy them in addition
though even when majority countries
cultures lay off and don't do
destructive things they're still the
seductive power of majority Society the
radio radio TV the newspapers trade
learning how to get jobs in the modern
world computers and computing is taught
largely in English is not taught an
Athabascan and Navajo so there's the
economic and the seductive power of
majority cultures but there are plenty
people in the world who are very happily
bilingual on the Navajos have done a
fairly good job about speaking Navajo
and also speaking English and getting
into modern society and the Danes do
very well at speaking Danish with inden
log and speaking English everywhere else
so I see a lot of possibilities for the
coexistence of minority societies with a
majority world Society
let me ask a follow-up question if I may
just just on that thought you've been
involved in helping New Guinea frame
conservation plan and a park system I
wonder if you tell us a little about
that effort and how your advice to them
might differ from what this country has
been doing internally yeah I could
comment on my work in conservation in
New Guinea until 1974 what I was doing
in New Guinea was basic research on
birds and I gradually realized that the
birds and forests that I loved were
disappearing and that I a as one of
people know most about New Guinea
biology had scope to start doing things
so in 1974 on 76 I began helping the
New Guinea area the governments of Papua
New Guinea and Indonesia in the Solomon
Islands plan their national park system
the government of Indonesia largely
adopted my plans for the National Park
System of Indonesia New Guinea and ever
since then each my trips to New Guinea
has been a combined research trip and
also conservation trip
my last two trips in Papua New Guinea
I've been working in the large oil
fields of Papa New Guinea managed by
Chevron I'm trying to help Chevron find
ways of reconciling oil exploration and
oil pumping with conservation and
they're doing a very good job of it I
think we have time for two more
questions and very quickly I have an
observation and a question my
observation is that and I agree with you
on your theory of how germs affected
civilization if you look at when
Europeans went to Africa Africa had many
indigenous microbes the Europeans did
not decimate the African populations as
a matter of fact was the reverse the
african microbes actually decimated the
europeans an example is a dr.
Livingstone the Englishman the Explorer
and also if you look at West Africa
compared to southern Africa the
Europeans could not stand you my groups
of West Africa but they could endure it
better in southern Africa and that's why
you have many Europeans they flourished
more in South Africa South Africa and
the Zimbabwe so I mean I agree with you
on that my question is I read your book
third chimpanzee and why sex is fun you
try to explain why humans especially the
females hide their Astros compared to
other primates and why humans do it in
private
are supposed to public but all of these
theories are red I think warm important
theories excluded and that is the fact
that humans over hundreds of thousands
of years ago developed consciousness we
will learn about the beam and therefore
we learn to hide our private parts and I
think that affected social behavior
which are things seemed into our genes
and then we acted accordingly we've got
to hide in our Astros and also doing
things with private I'd like to know
what you think about that if I can
rephrase that question slightly just to
put it in a theme that we've been
pursuing I think you're saying why shame
sure let me respond to both of those
questions that I'll take in the reverse
order on the second question there's an
important distinction via the title of
my book is not why sex is fun because I
don't know the answer why is that fun
the approximate answer of course you
idiot it feels good but the ultimate
answer why why did it evolve evolve in
humans for sex for us to feel good any
day of the month and after menopause
that's the subject of my book why is sex
fun and that's a big subject and yes the
issue of shame arises in there it's such
a big subject on that it's that I think
I will defer it to another occasion so
let me then go to the first question the
first question you are absolutely right
that in fact the main one of the main
obstacles to European colonization of
tropical Africa was African microbes
that was also the case in tropical
Southeast Asian New Guinea they were a
particular sort of microbes they were
not the so called crowd infectious
diseases they were instead diseases such
as malaria and yellow fever with animal
reservoirs on in southern Africa at the
tip of southern Africa it was um
different um their European germs
decimated the indigenous people of
southern Africa the Kois on people that
did not happen near the equator and I
think the main reason is that native
Africans near the equator that had cows
sheep and goats and the associated germs
for a long time but that is a very
interesting question and sir I suspect
you have an equally interesting question
my question relates to the difficulties
that academics face when they try to
write for the general public 25 years or
so ago anthropologist Ashley Montagu
tried to deal with some of this question
in a little book called up the Ivy I
wonder if you might have some
suggestions as to how we might
disencumber the academic culture from
the notion that because something is
successful and popular if therefore must
be worthless a an academic promotion
committee in the university I won't
mention actually stated this to a young
author who was an assistant professor if
your book sells more than 5,000 copies
we won't even read it yeah that is a
pervasive problem in academia what I
mentioned before that that if one is
appealing to the public the implication
is that you're doing it because you
can't do the real stuff which is hard
toughs on science and this is a attitude
that serves academics badly because in a
self or sense because after all are our
salaries here at UCLA come from the
state of California and from ultimately
from the legislature which is elected by
the citizens of California and we can't
communicate to the public my knowledge
is important it's going to show up in
our paychecks and this can certainly
show up in our research funds that's the
selfish attitude but a much bigger issue
of course is that the future of the
United States the president of the
United States depends upon an educated
citizenry and an educated government and
if scientists cannot tell people and
scientists cannot tell people in the
government what are the facts of science
and why science is important then the
government and the public are not can be
educated about public health issues and
days and collaring all the issues in
physics chemistry and biology I'll just
close that off with an anecdote the one
occasion that I met calls Sagan there's
a flu
before on he had died both of us have
gone through a bout of cancer and so we
swapped stories about our cancers and
then he was talking about the exactly
that problem what happens when
scientists talk about science to the
general public and Carl Sagan said
sometimes he gets envy and he gave this
wonderful example of if there is some
scientist he said a physicist who has
been spending his whole life studying
the hyperfine structure of the
molybdenum atom and then here am I
talking about the possibility of life in
outer space and along comes a reporter
the reporters hang on my latest
pronouncement and they don't care about
the hyperfine structure of the Lindemann
admin and that's a tough blows while the
ego of the former person but I would
answer that at the top Carl Sagan would
have been very good at making exciting
to the general public the hyperfine
structure could indeed
I wonder I wonder you know we've talked
about how hard it is for some
popularizers but certainly you yourself
are rich and honor and among them you're
the recipient of I guess what's usually
called one of the genius grants from the
MacArthur Foundation which gives its
recipients I believe it's five years of
unrestricted funding and I sort of
wonder now that you've got that some
years ago you've you've spent the money
I assume and I'm wondering what did you
do with it and what if anything did it
actually mean to your ability to further
your work what did I do with it in what
it means my lifestyle as I contemplate
my $19.00 watch it's not it did not
change change my consuming materialism
styles living it did permit me to switch
it encouraged me and permitted me to
switch my research from laboratory
science into writing for the general
public and during those five years that
I had the MacArthur funds from 1985 to
1990 it bought me freedom of time and
those were the years in which I did most
of the work in writing my first book for
the public the third chimpanzee and I
think if I had not gotten that award I'm
not sure that I in effect what the ward
did for me when I when the award was
announced my reaction was to get
terribly depressed for a week the most
depressed that I had been in my adult
life and I would the message was Jared
you've gotten this award great things
are expected of you look at what you've
done until now
you just haven't lived up to your
potential you'd better start doing more
important the award encouraged me to
start tackling bigger problems and
writing for the for the public and that
more than the money which quickly went
off in research grants not on $39
watching that need that psychological
boost was named consequence of the award
well I think we all know the MacArthur
Foundation a debt of gratitude for that
confidence boost otherwise we wouldn't
be having you here today and otherwise
you wouldn't have done so much to help
shape our thinking about the world we
inhabit I think what I'd like to do is
draw this conversation to a close I
would like to remind everybody if you're
interested in continuing this
conversation with Jared Diamond hired
you to go over to North Area C where
he'll be signing books immediately after
this and then later today at crown and
tomorrow at noon at the UCLA book zone
booth and if you have further interest
in the topic of science writing and
science writers I urge you to attend a
panel later today at 4:00 which will be
drawing together five of this country's
finest science writers to discuss some
of the issues that they deal with so
lastly let me ask you all to join me in
thanking Jared Diamond but also in
thanking each of you because it's smart
readers that make for smart and
engrossing books and